oh the one-sided interesting oh yeah
interesting a lot of happy people out
there yeah there we go
are we there we go are we doing
podcasting you're listening to the
dollop on the all things comedy Network
this is a biased erekle American history
podcast where each week two hysterical
men read a story from American history
how's this coming did I mess it up yeah
it's completely different and not with
anyway my name is Dave Anthony and I
read the story to my friend Gareth
Reynolds who has no idea what the topic
is going to be about it was fine now
your mom I just caught up in the fact
that your mom want to start with the
prayer go ahead let's start with the
prayer by Pam Reynolds is in the studio
oh do the one about eating you're gonna
make her do the eating prayer yeah do
the eating one that you said I know what
about eating oh wait a minute for what
we're about to receive may the Lord make
us truly thankful that's it make the
house you because we should literally be
doing that before every dollop and hey-o
like that we receive yes yes your
mommy's one nailed it for what we're
about to receive may the Lord make us
truly thank your mom just casually
thankful to another level like your
voice is on a new like what's happening
here your octaves are being explored
finally know I that prayer doesn't even
make sense to me for food I think we did
you to school I say that before everyone
you know we used to sing I might we used
to have to sing this of high school
before lunch god is great and God is
good and we thank him for this food
sorry what school where was this yeah I
went to a Jesuit school he went to
postal yeah that makes sense that's
definitely not a public school song oh
and you didn't I went to a Catholic
school and we didn't have to say even
after saying that well and they you know
I mean yeah I know kitchen with the
priest yeah yeah this got so personal
yeah honest but I'm gonna say that
prayer before every podcast no I also
what is there that you're gonna say
before they thanks God for what they're
about to get nope
I'll write it down for you guys this is
not gonna come now hit him with the
puppy you both present sip arguments
yeah all right well let's not do that
yeah do you have anything you want to
mention yes Dave I really do I want to
say that on New Year's Eve I will be in
Burbank California at flappers doing a
lot of new material that's December 31st
shows at 7:30 and 10 o'clock so you know
if you want to come out and watch me say
a bunch of stuff while we're all
probably drinking that is possible and
then also in addition in Australia I
will now be going to Adelaide in Perth
I'll be in Adelaide on the 23rd I'll be
in Perth on the 24th and the 25th you
can go to Garen's comm for tickets and
all that stuff and then I have an album
out it's called riddled with disease you
can go pick that up virtually on all
your digital platforms you can find that
as well on my website which I for
mentioned yeah and we're on tour we are
going to be in San Jose San Francisco
the starting in February it will be in
San Jose San Cisco Salt Lake City Denver
Cincinnati Pittsburgh Cleveland two
shows in Seattle both are on sale now
two shows in Portland both are on sale
now Houston Austin Dallas Oklahoma City
oh I forgot Vancouver Nashville st.
Louis Kansas City Des Moines West Palm
Beach tampa orlando louisville
indianapolis and then we're in Vancouver
on four AFL and the February 15 yeah you
have to get those through that you can't
get those through I guess I could do a
link but you got to get them through the
festival so yeah just for laughs website
that was a whole different animal also
I'm going to put up the Richard Jewell
episode on patreon it's the worst sound
of any podcast who ever I had recorded
it it when it hits the high and you know
when it goes up up high our voices it's
it's like a it's it's I tried that
people fix it but it's it's intolerable
but some people are still listen to it
yes five through I mean it's a great
it's one of the better episodes I've
ever done yeah it's a shame that the
sound guy didn't know that when the
thing goes into the red you turn it down
but
that's a hard thing to do what
industries red means good yeah yeah but
you would think as the sound guy you
would know the basic operation the
simplest like if a clown walked in and
he was like oh you should turn that down
that's David it's been a while and
you're still pretty hot we should also
say if you want to watch this you can go
to the all things comedy YouTube page
where there's a bunch of great stuff to
watch football and then we're was
talking I doing this George Zimmerman
Kickstarter definitely be banned from
Kickstarter a GoFundMe within the year
from the idea it's a great idea
you just need 10 grand pay people the
foam around playing the song so I could
kill a brother talking heads right you
do it George Zimmerman okay you do it
until he's really angry and then at
night you take one of those new
Bluetooth shower things and you pop it
on his window and you play it and then
he comes out yelling and you get to
shoot him because you're scared and you
just get to kill and then when he's gone
you just put a little hoodie over his
head that's right and you just go home
man handle this to talk to him I'm
telling you this is an idea it's good
it's has legs now you really generate
some really crazy [ __ ] but I think if we
put together 10 grand we can get ten
people thousand bucks a day he just farm
around with the Bluetooth speaker just
blasting psycho-killer tell until he
loses his mind it's great yeah it's
pretty good yeah yeah the dollop is
brought to you in part by Squarespace
Squarespace of course is a website
company Gareth uses it for his personal
website I use it for my personal comedy
hikes it's not a personal business
comedy website right I don't know what
the hell's happening personal website
his beard you putting up your thoughts
yeah well I mean yeah no I mean it's a
it's your personal website I'd say and
then we also have it all available but
it's not the Dalek personal website it's
the Dalek site yeah a dog sources site
they're all on Squarespace why because
we love Squarespace because the template
to look awesome it's super easy to work
with you can do whatever you want on
there you can sell stuff you can publish
your work you can blog it's hard to blog
these days log on Squarespace title
yeah yeah great blood yeah yeah so they
got the e-commerce functionality 24/7
award-winning support nothing to patch
you up great ever free and secure
hosting built-in search it's all there
what are you yelling at me for you did
it so head over to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code dollop to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that's squarespace.com enter
code dollop perfect Dave wasn't very
good okay thank you
we're also brought to you by joy Burt
which is not as a lot of people think a
joyful bird it is actually a furniture
company great furniture and what they do
is they build furniture for you yes and
then they ship it to you and it's and I
just I was just looking for furniture
for my new office and office yeah it's
yeah an office and a big boy and and I
was looking around for furniture and
it's every place is like so much longer
than your bird just takes right so
little time compared to everyone else
yeah and you don't have to go anywhere
that's right you can do it in your you
can do it nude you do it new I do it
nude look at my mother when you just
felt right okay yeah so I have new
j-bert chairs in my office also we have
Joe Byrd at at our home you have dry
Burt yep we've all got you ever we love
our drivers yeah dogs love the joy bird
everyone loves a job or it's very
comfortable birds not fans no they don't
like couches so with dry bread your
personal one-of-a-kind style it should
match your furniture bring your mood
boards to life with hundreds of
customizable pieces and over fifty
fabric offers options whether you're
more of a neutral beige or a bubblegum
pink person like Gareth I'm looking at
major bubble bung a boy look if you can
dream it Android bird can build it they
got free swath kits it's the whole thing
you call them up they got they got
people on the on the on the ready to
help you out expert people not just
random people oh that's helpful no it
sounds like it's gonna be pretty hard to
fix
who are you I'm Greg its quality
handcrafted furniture 365 day home trial
skip the furniture store and bring the
showroom to you greet furniture that
matches your own further style at joy
Burt calm / CEO joy Burt can help make
your dream space a reality today at joy
Burt calm / dog go to Joburg calm / stop
and receive an exclusive offer for 25
percent off your first order by using
code dollop boom that's what we call it
yeah dollop yep
also we're brought to you by native
which as as you and I both know is a
deodorant company a natural deodorant
company yep for the natural deodorants
if you don't want to put a bunch of
garbage on your armpits which is what a
lot of people are doing what you're not
supposed to do it turns out for some
reason yeah I've read a long time ago
aluminum's bad so native does not have
aluminum under there parabens and talc
you not just rub and junk under your
pits someone's a scientist it's filled
with ingredients found in nature such as
coconut oil shea butter moisturizer
tapioca starch which absorbs wetness
Nighy from what I hear I should start
eating it that's some delicious
ingredient it's right up your alley they
don't test on animals which is getting
back because that means the animals
stink
free shipping and return look it works a
lot of people think going to aluminum
free deodorant it means it's not gonna
work but it works I've tried it I use it
it works people love them the
ingredients that you know nothing weird
in there it's something for everyone
they've got all kinds of different
flavor not flavors but it smells yeah
coconut and vanilla it's the most
popular lavender and Rose you can burn
met eucalyptus and mint that's my jam I
like the eucalyptus nice no risk to try
they offer free returns and exchanges in
the USA so as I said I'm a eucalyptus
and mint gentlemen and if you want to
get in here and smell it I'm totally
cool with that
but it works like I'm not set an offer
yeah okay that's all decline okay so for
20% off your first purchase you visit a
native deodorant calm and use promo code
dollop during a checkout 20% off your
first purchase visit native deodorant to
calm and use promo code dollop during
check out now native telling you native
native deodorant it's the way to go yeah
get it yourself
deodorant down your eyes we also brought
to you in part by Casper Casper of
course is a sleep brand that makes
expertly designed products to help you
get your best rest one night at a time
we just bought one last week for fin no
great again wanted a new mattress yeah I
explained to him how Casper I expended
me the different mattresses and I
explained about Casper works and he was
like I want that one and the very first
day I took it out it does the puff up
thing it turns into big day small box
into a giant mattress and he laid on it
face down and he any mumbled this is
awesome you could have made your son
think you were a wizard on that that's
right by being like they sent the wrong
thing I might have blown it yeah you're
right you have all those staffs I'm not
great at things
Casper products are cleverly designed to
mimic human curves providing supportive
comfort for all kinds of bodies like
yours yes very round and you sink into
it thank you original Casper mattress
combines multiple supportive memory foam
for a quality sleep service with the
right amounts of both sink and bounce
Aaron you like the bounce right that's
my boy what they have three other
mattresses now the wave the essential
and the hybrid yeah so they're bringing
it comes right to your door in a box
small box open it up blue I say they're
big matches hassle free returns if
you're not satisfied Casper also has
other products like pillows and sheets
free returns free shipping returns in
the US and Canada you can be sure of
your purchase with Casper's 100 night
risk-free sleep on it trial ya get $100
towards slick mattresses by visiting
Casper comm slash dollop and using
dollop it check out that's Casper comm
slash dollop and using d'Alba checkout
terms and conditions may apply ya best
mattress can I ask you what the sheets
are like have you tried them I actually
haven't tried the sheets no I haven't
either you know but I from what I've
seen you put them over yourself and you
run around night and you're a ghost yep
good capper way to do it yes way to do
it good is it nice to be in America mum
as
oh it's normal voice it's lovely yes I
love it I love CNN I'm addicted to it
all right what just happened no no I
think I think my mother finally got my
letter of things that I'd say to Dave
Anthony things things what really weird
there yeah you know I mean no they
really inform you so that's a good place
to yes and they don't biased no no no no
they're bought yes right I do sometimes
go to folks good that's a great that's a
great ways to go really nice yes I do
like a lot of really great things have
happened
yeah because of Fox News yeah yeah yeah
yeah well I think the one thing is that
they've all got died here yeah yeah so
you can just and lie the way you want
yes yeah and they will look a bit slimy
and greasy yeah no I get what you'd
watch it that's lovely
yeah lovely I enjoy it I don't know why
I didn't write the screen right down
this guy's birthday so is there a date
god I wish that's the first time I think
I've ever bloom that blown that I'm
gonna say mmm what's in the estimate
right here 18 boys funny buddy six 1886
that's I'm going with okay do you want
to shout it or do you want to just say
it like a kid oh that's cool police can
do that young gentleman a Leo's junior
aloes junior how do you say al al Oh is
German name on the end right yeah you
wouldn't pronounce it but it's German
it's not French oh we're all German I'm
gonna say Alois are you and their
enemies now Louise its Eloise Eloise
okay all right Alois jr. was born in
we're gonna say 1896 you just said 1886
before 86 you're right that sounds
better it's not terrible start
he didn't have a great dad his dad
obviously out someone relates Elias
senior what are you talking about my dad
is my dad every day there's a leo senior
Alois oh and that's him as a baby yes
the man who looks like he has two little
moles making out under his nose he looks
as if he's got a snaggletooth like a
little maybe has a little yeah yeah
Elias jr. left home at 14 the older a
Louise swore he would never give the boy
a penny of inheritance so his father's
like I'm never gonna give him anything
beyond after 14 yeah okay
so his relationship with his stepmother
was also strange so he just bailed okay
and he went to he went to England and
then got a job at a hotel as a waiter in
Dublin Ireland okay now
Alois and Bridget met in Dublin at a
horse show in 1909 sure a horse show
obviously a show of horses his wife his
wife is not a horse good question we
know of yeah
well this is one that was legal anyway
she was a voice yes she was Irish in 17
he was Austrian and 27 okay I didn't I
didn't say where he came from
I am collect that so that's so you can
do the math there yeah well he's a yes
there's an age gap there's a legality
issues I'm born and he's born in 27
years old guys and he's born in 1886 no
the years 1909 he was 27 years oh you
want me to use mat of what year was he
born he was born and
82 they're doing he said 1909 so that's
18 yes I do
yeah we got it human calculator so Alois
what you laughing in Adam okay
Ali's told Bridget that he was a wealthy
hotel on our studying studying the
industry in other parts of Europe so
that's why it was that's why it was
entirely it said he told her that
because you don't that's not you saying
he was this you're saying he told her we
already know what he did which is he's a
waiter at that hotel Oh okay's but he's
instead like I'm just here studying all
the hotels I'm sorry if there's anything
I want to take back you know that's
right
cuz I can invest anywhere and I do and I
do he was handsome he wore fashionable
clothes and he had a handlebar mustache
we saw the mustache I would even call it
but handle dads oh that was his dad's oh
by the way his dad definitely looks like
if a wizard turned a pug into a man yep
yeah okay so he had a handlebar okay
gotcha yeah so uh so he he was great he
seemed like a man of the world the
Bridget right he's just foreigner guy
says he has a lot of money he sweep
sweep spread [ __ ] off her feet
sure okay quote everything he said was
so new and interesting that even his
broken English seem charming right and
because it sounds her new and
interesting because it is a lie yes
right
so that's why yeah let's White Lies
sound great because yeah you're coming
up they began seeing a lot of each other
she lived in a tiny flat on upper a
Stanhope Street okay
and now she'd met the man of her dreams
yeah in the sense that dreams aren't
reality yes right they started planning
their future together a year went by and
their romance just built now you feel
this build of heightened romance yeah
he's doing that hopefully soon yeah but
he's doing that he's about to undercut
it all with something what button and
truth
Alois was not a wealthy hotel as we know
it starting he was a waiter at the
Shelburne Hotel who had been hired
through an employment agency
I stayed at home shut up really I'm sure
with nothing okay we stayed it's a
Marriott what a beautiful story
I'm sure she's listening yes she won't
be she was she's not so so then
Bridget's father found this out he found
out that he's a waiter yeah and he's not
happy he did undercover
he'd have wanted to see what it was like
to be a waiter to make sure to establish
a great you would have Undercover Boss
say it's just fake he so William doesn't
think that this Eloise can provide for
his daughter right so he's like you got
to call it off so they elope they go to
London and they get married on June 3rd
1910 ok
Bridget's father is furious sure he
tries to get a Louise arrested for
kidnapping sure ok Bridget comes and
talks her dad out of it she that's not a
great way to start the whole marriage I
mean that that's a married yes and plus
I think the second the cops get hearing
back no I'm into it like it doesn't
sound good
18 at that point yeah which is basically
35 at that time right they had a son in
1911 so they're doing it they're having
a lot of the sex yeah no I think that's
we can gather that I'm just reeling in
the gas so is he
William was born sorry another young
William the son was born in Liverpool
okay which seemed to have ended the feud
with Bridget's father who made the trip
back to Liverpool for the baptism of his
first grandchild William Patrick Hitler
Patrick what Hitler Hitler that's right
and again he's from Austria so this is
this is a I'm sorry I'm just so parched
this is a speechless this is a okay this
is always Hitler was Alois Hitler junior
older half-brother of Adolf Hitler oh he
goes on to do big things
Steve yes did not as bridges to paint as
bridges father suspected party's not as
fun as it was a minute ago you know as
Bridget's father suspected the family
wasn't very poor his cousin a doff
wasn't doing much better wait half
brother a cousin half brother I'm sorry
I put cousin hey so yeah no it's his cut
it says yeah it's his brother sorry half
brother you're confused ever second okay
so Adolf isn't doing much better he's
living he's in Austria living in a
homeless shelter and in 1909 and then he
switched to a public dormitory for men
okay
that's right oh that's work great great
brain it's what we call locker room talk
and a Liverpool Alois went through a few
different jobs including working at a
restaurant a boarding house in hotel
what is it like with your wife at that
point when she's like remember when you
told me you were a millionaire and just
yeah I don't and he's like ah anyway I'm
gonna go see if I can be a milkman you
know it's you know you love the guys so
you're like alright he lied to me about
being like a decent person that's an
issue but you know also and obviously
it's not great and by the way clearly
not something that runs in the family
and as far as the oversell always was
not good with money and he eventually
went bankrupt okay
which is what Bridget's father said
would happen right so there was a lot of
called it yeah called it a lot of call
that's going on yeah you want to give me
another beer called this one so I always
do did what anybody gave you [ __ ]
together like your brother Adolf Sally's
do you do it any Hitler does in that
situation and he bailed on his family
sure first he went on a gambling tour of
Europe I'm mostly gonna be a head
Potawatomi gambling tour hope you come
watch me lose it all be at Foxwoods yeah
I'm going to Morocco where I'm gonna bet
wildly come on out guys we've been
having a lot of sadness of these shows
so that awesome plan didn't work out and
in May in 1914 he went back to Germany
where he sold safety razors safe right
and we all know safety razors yeah the
only razor that's safe that's right yep
when World War one broke out any chance
Ali's jr. had of reconnecting with
Bridget and Willie as he called him
Willie
were gone are gone for good yeah right
Bridget would now raise Willie alone
okay Alois fell in love I love his jr.
fell in love again in Germany and he
wanted to marry his new love Hedwig
Heidemann that's chairman was the most
German name German it's weird one more
time hide wick hide hide wig Heidemann
just doesn't sound German to me
I got an Irish energy it's very feminine
yeah yeah but he was excited today to
hide wick settle down now he wanted to
marry her but he was still married to
Bridget Yeah right getting divorce back
then it's very hard sure so he did what
Hitler's do and he faked his death so he
could marry so was she in Liverpool the
why she's in Liverpool raising Willy and
raising really yeah which is the sitcom
they started over there that did very
well on ITV actually yeah
now that dad's gone looks like I'm
racing Willy yeah that's right
on an all-new raising Willy but the
faking the death didn't thing didn't
work authorities found out and then they
found out and then they look into why he
would do that and they found out that he
was still married to Bridget while he
was married - what's the best-case
scenario by the way if I mean you've got
it if you're gonna fake your death you
really got to do it properly yeah that's
not the sort of thing where you want
people to be like hey wait yeah
here he is I mean there better be a head
yeah yeah exactly
thank you Dave for the outstanding had
to do it properly so in 1916 Alois was
prosecuted for bigamy he didn't go to
jail though because Bridget ended up
saving him when she told the authorities
she had legally separated from him so
she went and saved him well she's my
favorite character and raising Willy is
he knows one way to do it and that's his
way so everyone went back to their lives
years past Bridget's racing Willy alone
and safety right in Liverpool right not
much is known about Willy's time as a
youth but when he grew up Willy's uncle
Adolf was becoming known for his
speeches against the Treaty of
Versailles other politicians Marxist and
Jews yeah we read about that yeah
everyone knows that think we heard that
part someone might be learning it for
the first time what well let me turn
this up I know it was the Versailles
Treaty guy yeah back in England he made
this made things not great for Willy
right his uncle you know Hitler right
that's a bummer people and I was
thinking I could come to your class and
speak to your school today later what do
you think Willy with his uncle's rise to
power as Chancellor Willy found that the
Hitler's surname was kamek causing him
problems yeah and he started getting
laid off from every job that he landed
right
so I mean yeah for sure it's hard it's
one of the few lines as I approve he has
even done anything yet but Hitler's
everyone's like that guy's a deckhand
he's a problem yeah man imagine that
sensation yeah I'll be weird to see that
coming
yeah miles away yeah it'd be so where to
see it coming around yeah and stay in
there
yeah really weird yeah as a young man
William was described as a quote tall
dark young man with a small black non
Hitler s mustache well that's something
you definitely I mean I put that part
got put in later but clearly what kind
of mustache is it then it's just one of
these he here's like a regular kind of
guy who definitely talks like this
that's right that's right have you seen
my father nor have I he's got a smart
suit on yes I do
there's a double Windsor knot it might
be a little bit later but that's my
sleeve no this is me as an
eight-year-old
I'm very tiny at this have you seen this
woodcomb raising Willie I have not yeah
I really only had one perspective okay
mine I wouldn't listen to reason and
reason wouldn't listen to me
in 1932 William was 21 and he was making
plans to move to the United States okay
and he wrote his father did tell him
that's what he was planning on doing he
wrote Alois yeah okay but Alois wrote
back and talk to Willie into moving to
Berlin instead okay interested okay
mm-hmm Adolphe had a job for him yeah oh
no hopefully not hey you're gonna love
it
he's doing amazing sings over here so he
arrived in Berlin
I think he'd already seen him I want to
say he had seen him once when he was
younger but so pretty much total
separation I think I think I'm in one
letter convinces him to move I think I
left it up but I think he went over when
he was about 12 okay
and Hitler was giving speeches and he
and the first time he saw his uncle
Hitler uncle Adolf Hitler was giving a
speech in front of a bunch of people and
hiring him
so is oh I wish real gets this but he's
sort of enamored with his uncle well you
will get to so upon arriving Mehta great
sign for arriving with blenny goes any
in Berlin he goes and he meets with
uncle Adolf and they had a they had a
big family sort of group meeting sure in
Hitler's hotel yeah always good to get a
group of Hitler's together oh my god
just a good little brain so a lot of
young talk about moon shoots over a meal
yeah William quote Hillier wept and
raved that his family was ruining him
and threatened to shoot himself I just
killed myself which was his favourite
threat yeah right yeah until the end
crazy in the end it was like yeah go do
it boy who cried wolf no I really have
to be of course he shouted at me that if
I returned to England or or went to
America he would make it plain that I
wasn't related to him at all this is the
best time in the world to move to
America talk about regret I've just
shown you well see you later [ __ ] so
uncle a it off then became Chancellor of
Germany in March 1932 so that's the same
year he went over there yeah right
ground floor so I assumed he had he had
just missed I mean he was there for the
action right the the burning of the
Reichstag and there right I think it it
all works out the heat there were flags
that if he were against that he would
have record and he arranged for William
to take a job at a Reich's credit the
bank in Berlin okay say work for the
bank for much of the 30s job wasn't
great but being a Hitler was much better
in Germany that ended been in England
mmm-hmm that is a shelf life yeah he cut
his moustache so it was exactly like his
uncle Adolph that's tough to hear tough
to hear
not a great look and that it was only
only those two until Michael Jordan how
did letting people know that do you can
you just imagine how many [ __ ] dudes
how to Hitler muster oh no probably like
the mop top from the Beatles you know II
mean it's just like yeah give me the
Hitler oh cool hey what are you guys
doing you want to go to the soda place
tonight yeah this it's not NBD whatever
and and then he had his hair styled
exactly like his uncle paid off not
getting enough sweet nappa tizen William
went out using his name and look to get
ladies so he's rolling around being like
yeah I'm a Hitler can you believe it
well you know I tell it off a lot of
this stuff a lot of the stuff Adolph
says kind of comes from me ooh ooh nice
whoa no it's tremendous how much he
listens to me is absolutely tremendous
oh we're doing big things we don't big
things me and uncle ate off big huge
thing huge getting so many things done
what does it feel like when the
moustache touches szyskii yeah well why
don't you find out that's what I'm
insinuating my little hide wig
hmm maybe you could give me the Titlis -
you know I'm gonna all right this is
weird to do with my mother in the room
yeah for me okay
the independent quota despite
frustration at his own a low-ranking job
the young Hitler found himself invited
to fashionable dinner parties and was a
sought-after guest at country house
weekends where the Nazi elite gathered
to enjoy the spoils of their complicity
in the family connection also proved to
be an aphrodisiac and passport to the
beds of many young women his performance
however was said to have left many of
his conquests quote disappointed so he
[ __ ] in a sack I think also like his
uncle Hitler his uncle Adolf has some
really [ __ ] weird sex [ __ ]
does he yeah I read a little bit about I
haven't gone on but it's all like oh
that's really [ __ ] [ __ ] up like
stuff yeah it's at about dark stuff but
it's just it's uncomfortable and weird
but you know it turns out Hitler not a
normal guy really yeah
were there any signs no okay came out of
nowhere so so he's he's he's working and
he's working it to get ladies which is
what if you're a 21 year old dude or 20
you know you're doing you're working the
Hitler metric yeah it's like you're in
Eastwood yeah that's right so William
pushed his uncle to get him a better job
so he doesn't like to see living this
like nine-to-five is just sort of like a
regular job and not have a good job and
then at night he's out yeah all the big
parties all the ladies are like oh
you're in yeah it's really great tell me
again what the Train is like there are
also a lot of we've never done in
podcasting a lot of upper upper crust
English people we're in Germany at the
time enjoying this all this fun stuff
it's almost like it's class-based that's
so weird
so he's what well no I was thinking
about um
the king that stepped down because he
will they thought there was a connection
with Germany and him yeah yeah yeah
okay Edward yes yeah the German
connection just think about the upper
crust people I'm sure when's your Queen
gonna die yeah yeah she's she's they're
just rich [ __ ] right the Royals
they're just not some people think she's
just eight corgis stuffed and lady's
skin so his uncle gives him a different
job it's also not a great job at the
Opel automobile factory and then later
as a car salesman
so that's he's like not he thinks I'm
Hitler's nephew I should be rolling in
this right I want to be convicted of war
crimes that's right the Fuhrer was
apparently annoyed with William it off
did not want to be accused of nepotism
okay of all the [ __ ] that I think
one that really really I do not want
hung around my [ __ ] neck is that I
helped out my family people will talk do
you have any idea this sort of looks I
would get if I were to do something as
simple as that
right but that's sort of what you know
these authoritarian fascists do they
they make it seem like they're doing the
right thing while they're actually right
they do - good thing you can imagine
that happening no I'm in it well I can't
imagine the good things yeah well he
ranted a Hitler ranted quote I didn't
become Chancellor for the benefit of my
family and no one is going to climb on
my back hither clearly did not like
William because he began to refer to him
in public as quote my loathsome nephew
yeah yeah at this time
Alois was reported by the AP to be his
father
oh I love Louise yeah it was reported
was reported by the AP to be the owner
of a Tea Room and Germany okay so that's
what he's doing
okay so he's just totally off to the
side yeah there's our orchestra archit
you know Texas said do you want to do
the fear thing and I said not rather run
a Tea Room I like kings and I like a
little dress that's less into murdering
anyway million are your hot cocoa yeah
okay let me know if you need anything
else I'm gonna take this number off okay
so so now he's very much enjoying his
fame William or maybe it's more intense
when he does it like this will happen
but Bagel Bites you Malita but the Bagel
Bites you will love them here is your
check time
so 26 year William goes back to England
in 1937 where he gave an interview to
The Daily Express which was carried all
over the world under the headline quote
William Patrick Hitler has an Irish
mother okay is that a big that's a big
stink I guess okay in the article he
said his uncle was his idol but quote he
finds it difficult to convert his mother
a Catholic to Nazi socialism mom she's
not getting on board it's her whole
background hold the whole thing about
her island of people being murdered and
genocide slaughtered by she's one of
these people that finds it extremely
evil it's just Catholic he said his
mother had lost her British citizenship
when she married a louise and became an
Austrian oh so she's a no I guess I
guess back again you couldn't have dual
citizenship so when she'd married him
she immediately became I'm just living
abroad but then yeah but the remember he
bails on her alright oh no and so now
the the Austrian consulate refused to
renew her papers so she's she's
essentially a woman without a country
she's country listen yeah weird
so william declared himself to be quote
the only legal descendant of the hitler
family and then crossed his arms like a
dog did for the interviewer okay so this
is a real he quipped quote that gesture
must be in the blood i find myself doing
it more and more oh boy this nassau
i can't help it
we like this all the time he posed for
photos in the stances made famous by his
uncle back in germany uncle Adolf
pressured when he was back in Germany
uncle Adolf pressured William to cement
his loyalty to the Nazi regime by
renouncing his British citizenship and
taking a high-ranking position within
not and within the Nazi Party so now
he's like you got to drop the British
[ __ ] which is on the German to do and
now I'm gonna give you a position [ __ ]
an awesome new party right which he
didn't he did want to get a nice job but
and that
not really the job he wanted okay right
he wanted like all the upside of
nepotism without the like evil nature
yeah yeah I think he wanted like a
private industry job that was awesome
right something in the private sector
yeah what we call a Biden gig that's
right but Liam was worried when was
worried now that he would be trapped in
Germany when the war broke out and he
refused nobody else felt like that yeah
yeah and he still wanted some sweet
nepotism right so he tried to blackmail
his uncle Adolf Hitler Jesus now this is
before you know how bad it yeah the idea
of blackmailing Hitler no no he's not a
good guy no I think if I do it right and
techniques like a surgery but it's very
surgical Hans Frank who was nicknamed
the butcher of Poland and he was a
foreman not former Nazi lawyer would
later reveal that William wrote to Adolf
and threatened to expose Hitler's quote
unusual family history interesting the
independent quote it was a veiled threat
that he would confirm the long-held
rumor that Hitler's paternal grandfather
was in fact a Jewish merchant right
Leopold frankenburger who had an affair
with Adolf Hitler's grandmother Maria
during her time in service to the family
Graz which was not not real it's not
real right but it would undercut ya know
if you're running around saying oh by
the way excusing everything I said makes
total sense
it's just a small punishment just the
title of attention please so uh he gave
in to I am Wow
so William is I think the only guy we
know who stood up to Hitler everybody
for a while yeah but there were guys guy
comes up but way I'm like went right at
him so he didn't give
he didn't get him the job you wanted but
instead he gave him money to gain the
equivalent of $250,000 oh yeah that's
some serious go away mom yeah that's
good Jewish obviously the relationship
is over
whatever quote I shall never forget the
last time he sent for me he was in a
brutal temper when I arrived walking
back and forth we call regular mood yeah
regular Hitler walking back and forth
brandishing his horse hide whip he
shouted insults at my head as if we he
were delivering a political oration his
ventually sorry his vengeful brutality
on that day made me fear for my physical
safety according to William that was the
last time he ever saw his uncle Hitler
and that's a good thing yeah he left
Germany in January 1939 and returned to
Britain but being a Hitler was now even
worse than when he left in 1933 right he
got a very frosty reception right to
separate itself from his horrible uncle
he then wrote an article for Look
magazine titled quote why I hate my
uncle oh gee this is you do not keep
poking this bear you know I mean you get
you let you exit stage right you're none
why'm is due it just seems very much
like a guy who just wants to feel good
at the time right there was a lightning
impulsive thinker yeah right imagine
that it was published on July 4th 1939
an article with a six-page of photo
illustration was he crossing his arms
like genetically defined adduce in that
article devar my guess is maybe at a
different pose yeah he told the world
what it was like to be a Dolf Hitler's
nephew including the first time he met
his uncle and a rally quote being very
close to my father at the time he
autographed this picture for me he had
cakes and whipped cream Hitler's
favorite dessert I was struck by his
intensity his feminine gestures and
there was dandruff on his coat he would
be like curious bring me his hands I
laughs your baby's head only he wrote
about the dark family secrets quote when
I visited so he's still releasing the
dark family secrets even though he was
paid to not yeah Wow
you don't you look magazine not a
respected publication it's not okay no
the Democrats could learn something from
William quote when I visited Berlin in
1931 the family was in trouble gely
ruble the daughter of Hitler's and my
father's sister had committed suicide
everyone knew that Hitler and she had
long been intimate and that she had been
expecting a child a fact that enraged
Hitler his revolver was found by her
body and so the implication being that
he is [ __ ] his cousin yeah and then
and then she got pregnant by him and
then he killed it right he explained the
uncle Adolf loved entertaining beautiful
women that he had suicidal tendencies
and his intimidation tactics and the
intimidation tactics he is to control
the regime right so I was you know
oppressing within Germany right when his
mother was going on a lecture tour at
the invitation of publisher William
Randolph Hearst oh wow to support a book
she had just written titled my brother
ate off geez so cashing in ya gotta make
some money cool thing about capitalism
someone's doing genocide write a book
right put an article the paper yeah yeah
I've been truly I'd like this is where
the media is like a sympathetic look at
the Hitler's I mean at this point you
know America is like it's Hitler bad or
good
obviously Europe is more no he's bad
he's here he's bad but yeah I mean
people still want that people want the
goods on them they want to hear the the
gossip in the high pass so they trying
to cash in on Hitler's they're just like
us
now obviously no one knows about the
genocide all aspects of
Hitler at this point that's coming down
the road right although let's be fair
America did turn away some ships full of
Jewish people
sorry we're [ __ ] why I'm decided to
join his mother on the US trip okay in
my brother ate off Brigitte said quote
in Vienna Adolf Hitler had been on the
brink of destitution by day he worked as
a laborer shoveling snow and beating
carpets at night he flopped down in a
men's hostel okay which yeah because one
of the reasons Hitler rose to power is
because they're just economically
devastated oh and you know yeah a lot of
guys were doing that yeah she said the
threat of being drafted was worse for
him and that ain't off Hitler then fled
Austria and came to Britain to avoid the
draft interesting the Fuhrer stayed with
her between November 1912 and April 1913
which actually was the British sitcom
the forgotten one the Fuhrer and her
that great summer flick Fuhrer and
Liverpool yeah Bridget wrote of
discussions they had around the kitchen
stove she claimed Hitler was into
astrology and that it influenced many of
the Reich's military strategies that's
always good to hear also that she
persuaded him to clip and restyle his
handlebar mustache into what became his
famous look oh is that right well but
it's not I thought it wasn't okay God
historians now call Bridget's book a
work of total fiction okay and they
completely reject the claim that he went
to England in 1912 oh the whole thing is
[ __ ] she's just fully cashing in on
right Hitler's day did what am I wrong
that I thought the mustache came from
like when you were wearing like gas
masks during combat oh I don't know and
you'd have to shake out the chaplain had
it was a right actually found it
actually I don't think I haven't here
but there was an article I came across
it was like these are the guys that are
wearing the Hitler or Chaplin mustache
in Congress and all the guys now we
Chaplin are you feta Hitler I'm actually
a fan of Hitler who's this Chaplin while
on the tour with his mother William saw
his own opportunity to make money people
want to hear about Hitler especially
from family members
he was offered a contract to write a
lecture in the US he spent the next few
years giving lectures around America
based on his essays why hate my uncle
and the follow up what the German people
are thinking so he's [ __ ] right look
you gotta make money baby yeah yeah but
it's mm-hmm from December 26 1939
Hartford Courant quote young Hitler
talked at some length Hitler
yeah it's their call makes him sound
like scrappy-doo from Scooby Doo
or the little Yoda baby yeah young
Hitler Lord Sheldon like The Big Bang
Theory spin-off young Hitler young
Hitler talked at some length of
Germany's chances in the present
conflict of little known weaknesses in
the Nazi war machine of the Nazi
propaganda system which he says is so
well developed that it is too good only
the ignorant Germans are now completely
taken in by mr. Goebel and his
propaganda yeah that didn't sound
familiar
that doesn't that makes you feel
confident his election yeah it's it's
like he's basically saying well
everybody most people see that it's
[ __ ] but just these [ __ ] rude we
rats of fate we're at the phase where
it's just like I mean look there's just
a certain sect that just believe
everything and it's dangerous anyway
let's see how this warp the tides about
to turn on that anyway we're gonna
impeach oh wow really his lectures were
well attended quote of the visit of the
Fuehrer's 27 year old nephew to Hartford
was the occasion of much curiosity as
soon as word of his arrival was noised
about the hotel visitors sought him out
simply for the unusual sensation of
being able to shake hands with him and
say hello mr. Hitler and by the way in
today's world without question he would
be on Dancing with the Stars Oh
hundred percent yeah absolutely I'm
sorry come to dance with me lately or
whatever it's called in English yeah
Strictly Come Dancing morning yeah it's
good but could we distort it
as one man expressed it after what I
think of as uncle it was one of the
oddest oddest experiences of my life to
greet him and call him by his name yeah
Wayne was described as like there is
negative celebrity we just recognize any
celebrity now is positive but that's a
good example of it back that was but the
guy was still going to see him in paying
money to see me exactly you know there's
lightning his pocket it there's no it's
no different today than then you just
want to see the celebrity and a
fascination even if it's someone who's
completely ruining society you're like
well I mean I want to get a picture
Wayne was described a picture of Tom
Arnold yeah William was described as
quote a quiet friendly and personable
young man who obviously has a great
store of knowledge about conditions in
present-day Germany and it was not
afraid to say exactly what he thinks he
resembles his famous uncle and then he
has the same mystic brown eyes but in
respect to character and attitude he's a
totally different sort of person yeah
read that other article a is the same
mustache that says been genetically
brought down some papers had a good time
the Boston Globe 1939 quote hold on to
your seats folks Hitler in person will
speak in boston at ford hall forum on
sunday sunday october 29th
relax it's it's not 8 off it's his
nephew why a badger killer
damn it it was he was now saying it off
had him arrested and tossed into a
concentration camp oh my god so he's
blow up the story a little bit there's a
lot to unpack there I honestly was
hoping so much that there was not a
clarifier in there my god we've got we
got to get out of here
Hitler's yeah so there's a big night
where they went and arrested tons of
political opponents and he said even I
got picked up in that sting and they
kept me in jail for a day and then they
threw me in a concentration camp system
by the way that's one of those stories
as well that builds over time like you
so it's like how Brian Williams when he
talked it's like yeah well we took on I
was shot five times in the leg from an
RPG oh my god he's still doing it but
that but that I would probably do the
same thing if I was Hitler's nephew I'd
be like ya know I was in a concentration
camp
hey and then I broke right out of there
I did a Brook right out of that I killed
all the Nazi guards I did and then I
left there right away and then I came
over here cuz I was like America's the
best
also go Celtics I've loved him since I
was a boy a couple days later the
Philadelphia Enquirer headline it quote
uncle wouldn't get me a good job give
you 250 grand you [ __ ] I do not want
to have Hitler's back of anything but
this dude's also a [ __ ] my uncle offered
to get me a job with the Hamburg
American line but I told him the salary
was too small I went on got a job with a
bank he's just he's just yeah because he
hated the job with the bank I find that
if I left Germany because my uncle and
his friends were against me
good lord it's mine to write your life
like a comic book the wilkes-barre
evening news headline quote Hitler's kin
here that's not this is weird
well I was reading all the headlines and
I was like oh my god they so the the
papers down the line on this tour are
trying to come up with different
headlines than the ones had already been
made right and it's getting harder it
was getting hard right hard right
he's a hip ler that's all I got boss
it's been a long night in what's bar he
told the crowd of nine hundred that the
Nazis popularity was waning in Germany
so he's he's it's a big [ __ ] tour like
he's making money right you know right
like he has a Squarespace website yeah
right yeah a few months later he was
saying the Hitler leaders all lived in
castles and palaces and had eight or ten
limousines ate caviar and had State
ballets at their command so he's just
[ __ ] cuz there's no one he could
fact-check right exactly
fake news yeah yeah after spending some
time in the u.s. William apparently
decided he wanted to fight against his
uncle Adolf Hitler in reality not just
then this mythical world he's created in
March 8th 1944 the edition of the
Democratic chronicles said William had
quote been trying
for the last few years to enlist in the
British American or Canadian Forces and
he was turned down on each attempt when
the authorities came to that part of the
questionnaire in which applicants list
relatives who are or have been in the
Armed Forces of enemy nation
my cousin Chad that is everyone so we
can move oh sorry oh I got an uncle my
uncle is named Adolf Hitler and I think
he does something in Germany I'm not
sure what it is but in some forces there
sorry enough
Hitler yeah and I let's circle back on
my cousin Chad because I think that's
the interesting one I think we're I
think we're gonna hold you right there
you talk about Adolf Hitler yeah yeah
little mustache yeah yeah little
cutiepie got no comb-over yeah little
yells a lot big Yeller it's a big Yeller
yeah yeah so I guess that's it and like
I said Oh cousin Chad we're not gonna
need to we're good worth we're gonna
take a pass now you're literally the
only person that we're not gonna let
fight in World War two I would I again
want to point out that I am super wait I
forgot about black people we try to keep
them out for a while right yeah no but
we let them in after all but you
specifically ready only human being we
don't want fighting for our side because
of my bone spurs now the anal cysts what
oh my uncle al says yeah yeah all right
well can I have some of these myths no
all right well see ya so they all told
William Patrick that there was no room
for him in the military okay he wanted
to get into one of the Air Forces
because he felt that he might have a
shot at killing his uncle Adolph Wow
not getting anywhere with the military
William then wrote to President
Roosevelt okay which FDR saw it and was
like oh that's a [ __ ] PR coup that
also make Hitler crazy
shockingly if you knew what was going on
yeah so the FBI did a background check
they found no evidence of subversive
activities and William enlisted in the
u.s. Navy in 1944 Wow
he must be so happy yeah it's also got
to be really weird if you are like next
to him I'm working I'm the Navy yeah
you'd be like sorry what's your deal I
mean imagine the Hitler this shirt
what's your real uh what's your real
this shirt say and I but I don't think
Hitler was a uncommon name because when
I was searching newspapers I kept
running across like Sammy Hitler like in
America just guys constantly
yeah right no it's like when you have
the same name as a serial killer you're
like by the way I am NOT a Bundy I'm not
Ted Bundy yeah yeah so he said on Wayne
Macy it's different
amazing I hate clowns he served as a
pharmacist mate which later or you mate
with them yeah yeah you wanna have sex
again have a baby that makes it work
okay just doing a job that layer that
was later changed to Hospital Corpsman
no more nicer job there's gonna be more
corpsman in England soon right and I'm
like oh sorry cool yeah you're gonna
have more with the NHS soon more
corpsman in England I think oh yes
definitely started already
yeah and America is gonna be running it
no boy that's me [ __ ] up your healthcare
give us a chance you guys are gonna have
so much fun watching them one with
diabetes dies because they can't afford
the medicine did you see that video of
them I can remember what was for but it
was just someone went over there just
was telling people it was like how much
do you think it cost to get an ambulance
oh yeah I don't know hundred dollars
like no twenty five hundred you talking
about how much to get to hold your baby
oh I hold your baby thirty-five dollars
if you have a c-section
cost $35 to hold your
baby afterwards baby America's great Oh
crazy oh that's like the baggage fee of
hospital fees and then I'd feel what 20
told me oh yeah a magical doctor yes
so William ended up being wounded and
discharged after serving 18 months he
got a Purple Heart
like his uncle had a black one that's
whoa
and then William Patrick Hitler dropped
off the map after the war the last name
Hitler was not a great one to have
wonder why willing changed his surname
to Stuart Huston and married German Bor
born Phyllis JA a jean-jacques he tried
to distance himself from his previous
life and really anything to do with his
genocidal uncle Adolf Hitler Alois also
wanted to distance himself from his
brother in Germany he had survived the
war and when questioned by the Brits
they said he was quote blameless and
scared stiff of being associated with
the Fuehrer's activities we of course he
was yeah everybody was in Germany at
that point yeah well literally exactly
right it doesn't matter were definitely
people are like he's the best and they
were like I never knew him but
apparently because of the his whole
Hitler's whole nepotism thing like so
I'll always just kept running his tea
room until you know he couldn't anymore
but that was just he just kept running
the night cream but now I don't have to
say this William and Phyllis moved it to
a Patchogue Long Island I'm sure it's
wrong sure has to be patc h OG e oh that
sounds right the toe oh yeah yeah it'll
be no it'll be silent yeah after the so
William was known to neighbors as patty
I have a German actor nobody's covering
it up now maybe or maybe he's trying you
mean he's fighting for the German good
morning it's come over later for some
clovers and Dublin Scotch that's fine
I'm from top of the mornin Oh William
used his medical training from the Navy
to set up a business that analyzed blood
samples for hospitals I had a feeling
you would he set up a laboratory in his
house and he called it Brookhaven
laboratories sure they had four sons
Louise Howard Ronald Howard Ronald Brian
William and Alexander Adolph buddy Barry
I don't move on that's the first kid
that Harry I don't know why you what the
[ __ ] they were they're just no a doll
what are you doing Maddy how about a D
just a little wink I mean I guess they
were thinking like well eight off is
such a super common name in Austria
Germany but but not thinking like oh no
one's gonna name their kid a dog except
for the clothes gonna be a drunk are
[ __ ] psycho right Yeah right
they were said to be a secretive family
one neighbor quote they were very
private everything was kind of a secret
Pat wasn't all that friendly he kind of
stayed to himself he'd say hello but he
kept very distant Phyllis would never
tell you anything personal Wow
so we there in the witness protection
program well I mean just imagine like
you just wouldn't want to slip exactly
so you wouldn't talk to anybody right
right hey you keep it all very surfacey
and I said tell me about your family and
he jumped out that window neighbors
never knew they were the last of the
paternal line of Hitler's the kids
upbringing seemed quote all-american
aggressively so haha this one's named
New York City yeah I never said they
were aggressively American he decided
for the 4th of July we're going big
again this year we love it here
it's a little boy too a sparkler as a
matter of fact I have an idea to turn
all little boys into spotless but by I'm
sorry there's definitely could be a
series called Hitler try to camp
yeah but the family was just a Miss
distance from everyone else they spoke
German at home neighbors thought William
had a slight resemblance to the man who
had carried out the Holocaust a woman
who grew you know did you ever hear
about that guy in Germany who killed all
those Jews no oh I know his name yeah
when you say nein you look more like him
right your hands Allah no no yes what
was his name again
he was um history history history you'd
look just like him sounds just like what
he would say nope
what is your problem I'm leaving your
Independence Day barbecue love America
it doesn't say back in Patti a woman who
grew up nearby said her father used to
say to her mother quote doesn't Patti
look a lot like Adolf Hitler and another
time her dad told her mom quote I just
saw Patti mowing the lawn and he turned
around real quick and my god he looked
exactly like Hitler you know Patti when
you're mowing the lawn and the light
hits you right it's just so Adolf Hitler
it's no no the light when it hit you
Clark Gable's what I get no not at all
yeah I get a lot of clock Gable no it's
super Hitler Chaplin sometimes at most
no I don't get any of that I get just
full Hitler nah I'm gonna poison you
okay
yes sir I'm gonna take off my daughter
all right maybe move I think we're gonna
move okay yep just say you not see
anything well the girl the young girl
would play army men against Brian and
she would be the Americans and Brian
would be the Germans the kids in the
neighborhood lied like to imitate
Williams accent but his sons had a
normal childhood and graduated from the
local high school some Germans in local
Germans and in Long Island did know but
didn't feel the need to blast it out to
the world okay
the brothers grew up and discussed
amongst themselves what to do they
decided to never marry and never have
kids
Wow but just imagine like just having
having such like a diabolical blood in
your system
ya know in living like we can never have
kids yeah that's what I'm not having any
yeah yeah but that is amazing to bit to
self be like my mayor dad yeah but to be
like we are so there is so much evil in
us that we yeah whatever yeah yeah just
before he died William told his friends
and neighbors who he really was William
Stewart
Houston slash Hitler died on July 14th
1987 in Long Island he was buried next
to his mother at the holy holy [ __ ]
Cemetery in Coram New York the family
considered leaving the grave unmarked
but decided instead to bury him with a
fake name that brought him peace
syllabic fake pants Alexander became a
social worker sorry Alexander and off
became a social worker Lewis and Bryan
had a landscaping business and lived
together in 2006 a reporter tracked them
down but they refused to be interviewed
they said they were going to tell their
story themselves and that they had a
lawyer and an agent and we're writing a
book yeah I mean they have no story
except for we weren't Hitler
so that's the movie [ __ ] where does it
start
what starts on us and have not Hitler we
are a credits so you're just like normal
American kids but you had a last name
yeah but I think once every 20 pages
someone goes hey aren't you related to
Adolf Hitler and we'll be like well
demurrer will be like nah kinda and then
everything else about a picnic about a
company picnic this is oh this is a
movie now it's book - what would you do
jumping the gun to a movie we're a book
that it's a book it's a book and it's
about a company picnic and every now and
then the whole book is about a comedy
picnic doesn't have to be if you have
something you think is better that you
guys are done I don't think anything's
better I think that it's really bad what
about if we're friends with a magical
bear that's a whole different idea hole
in our under a whole different genre
okay then let's stick to the company
picnic you well in love okay I didn't
fall in love with that I don't like that
you're the one pictured it to me at this
point if I'm not I I'm saying that
there's literally no book here except
for you saying I'm I'm not Hitler which
that's that's the book right but get
some a no no no but the book is about us
trying to convince you to do the book
it's about you pushed back on doing the
book you don't want to do it and that's
the book and it's the story of this
meeting and then maybe we make it into a
movie maybe we don't but either way I
think this is a great project and again
it's all about our name and how we're
not him and it's so it's not about
anything it could be I mean what are you
trying to do over here right now but
nothing I just want you to leave my
office okay so this is a book about a
guy who loves his office
he's insane about it but two guys who
don't want to say they're related to
Hitler cuz they kind of were but they
kind of weren't are in it and it's this
guy struggle yeah to get these guys out
of his office yeah well you guys
definitely stick around like Hitler's
yeah no well we should yeah we're having
kids I don't know if we told you that
there's gonna be generation we're like
bedbugs okay we're there their names and
locations were withheld by the reporter
and another author of the book the last
of the Hitler's quote at their via
vehement and repeated requests by the
way they would be Doc's don't can you
guys not say where we live who we are
just not
I put that out there you know what I
mean some people have reservations about
us the home the family grew up in
eventually because they moved out
eventually came a crack house for a
while
apropos then a contractor moved in in
1999 and he fixed it up when he was
fixing up he found blood lab equipment
and German newspapers behind a wall
board that has to make you feel good
hey who lived here before some Hitler's
okay this is a bunch of blood and I
don't want the place anymore at one
point a German filmmaker came by and
told the contractor a Hitler had lived
in the house contractor said quote I was
like a Hitler lived here and ran a blood
lab what is this the boys from Brazil
all right contractor New York but it's
not like it was a huge secret when
Louise was asked if he was worried that
a play being written about them in 2006
would bring attention he said quote
don't worry we're used to it
you people knock on our door every week
asking us about it
so so but no one ever wrote about them
because they're like well these guys
didn't do anything register bunch of
dudes Williams wife died in 2004 and
then the brothers I think most the
brothers are dead or maybe not I
actually didn't you can't find the
information rather than that right look
fine so do you think they've count the
lines carried on oh yeah well I know
that they're on the other side there are
definitely living Hitler's in Germany
that they're definitely I think the
maternal side or whatever this is the
paternal side the paternal side just uh
nothing mmm it's done which probably is
[Music]
yeah it's hard to know it could who
knows the Hitler's could have been great
people after this by the way in America
a Hitler could if it was like the same
thing could totally run for president
and get traction listening yeah yeah
yeah right now Hitler could yeah right
now yeah
but I mean in our like in our world in
America it's like we have people who
commit more crimes and we're like well
every president of our that's the cool
thing about presidents is they all
commit work right yeah and then we're
like oh we just need there's only three
families we can pick from so there was a
really great New York Times article
about the guy going to meet up with him
a lot of this was taken from
what's-his-face is uh Billy Hitler's
writings right and then there's just a
bunch of articles I got I took a lot of
from newspapers CNN I read something
about a New York Times and the
independent I love to hear CNN it's made
me really excited very great
I think crack calm yeah find the guy who
I don't know Matt Burton II did the
research for this episode it's I've been
sitting on this for like a year well it
was a very interesting I wasn't sure
yeah it's interesting right it's not
hilarious and then there's not a lot of
information there obviously he makes a
lot of stuff up so it was a mmm but it's
something it's a cool story yeah yeah
what a weird thing to not want to
continue your line of yes that's me you
know I wish I wish the Kardashians would
make that decision well there's so many
people that could have done it yeah the
Bears and the Bears in Germany like
there's a shitload of people that could
really stop there if people but again
you would need to punish those lineages
in this day and age which does not seem
to happen yeah they're the cult of
celebrity in a way there's a woman who
writes for The Washington Examiner and
she was of course after Korman law she
was saying how Bernie Sanders is
anti-semitic because
you got a roll with it you know I mean
you gotta take the best stuff yeah and
and then she was tweeting about it and
someone was like well yeah but your
grandfather was a Nazi collaborator and
I believe Croatia so maybe you should
just nip your [ __ ] in the bud yo well
that's it but they don't locked if you
look at Mussolini's granddaughter is
just a straight-up fascist - holds
office in in you know like yeah they but
that's but again I mean that is it's
yeah if it's this tough thing where it's
like people can get by I mean the fact
that Liz Cheney is in our government
yeah making points it's like how is this
not like well because if you don't if
you don't actually prosecute them yeah
then then they just keep leaving and
then there's then their children do the
same thing because that's how they've
been raised but also not to get crazy
if you think about the like the way that
the Democrats now are what they're
trying to do is be like we are the moral
authority we are the moral line and it's
like well then why after Iraq prosecuted
in our government why is they voted
george w bush at football games sitting
next to ellen yeah being like hey like
it just does not because if you don't
come down on it yes BK and because I am
because not only that because aren't
because we don't demand it because our
attention spans are so short and stupid
that we're unable to go like that guy
should be in The Hague right you know
should 100% be in The Hague and you know
I mean that's the problem though if you
go halfway and you're like I didn't lie
about the war but I did support it then
how can you prosecute them because then
your whole party is decimated but then
how right now can't like you would not
then how right now are you being like
the I mean and again this is not like
Pro Trump at all but how are you like
this man it deserves to be impeached
like yeah we had worked war criminals
though the same people and our
government is at a set complicit for
that yeah
anyway Gareth rounds calm
I am Reynolds how many days calm calm
Pam Reynolds calm are you doing dates
yeah yeah thanks for doing a big tour of
the Hitler name I am oh no Davis Oh Dave
Davis name big name very poor a big fan
of the Hitler name yeah not the people
no no just the name that cachet I'm
trying to find the name of the woman who
was like how dare you well I just I just
related to Hitler I just love that
you're related to Hitler and you're
calling Bernie Sanders whose family died
in the Holocaust an anti-semite Dave
that requires a little bit of research
Tonya Tianna low Tianna low Johnna low
writes for the DC examiner co-host of
the political pregame and is related to
a Nazi formerly of the USC econ review
is saying that a man whose family was
killed in the Holocaust is an
anti-semite so you have a Nazi that's
how fascism happens that's literally
fascism when you when you undo history
yeah that's how fascism happens okay and
blah and it's unbelievably easy oh my
god it's like you can do it in five
minutes like making sea-monkeys at this
point it's very interesting to watch the
British in this election start going hit
there they're just lying and no one's
doing anything and you're like yeah did
you guys not watch just season of
America come on I mean they were like
flipping out about I was like yeah guys
that's actually actually how it works
yeah no it doesn't matter and then the
cool thing is that the Liberals attack
the left one on the right so that really
helps yep well it's check it out real
good thank you thank you thank you for
inviting me your well yeah it's very
nice can I have a goldfish yeah yeah
how'd it go horses came forward yourself
thank you not a real one